all right I hope everybody had a good
weekend because it's it's getting going
it's almost time for the first 2020
Democratic primary debates this thing is
really getting going in earnest I guess
we could say and there are a lot of
different things I want to talk about
related to this first series debate one
is really two debates okay there are 20
candidates who are participating in the
first debate which will be on NBC News
at the end of next week
will I be live-streaming commentary of
the debates
maybe we'll see we'll see a depends on
if there's interest that's a lot of has
a lot of live streaming in addition to
the regular show but there's a good
chance I will do it so the reason
they're splitting this up into two parts
even though it's debate number one is
that it's not practical to have 20
people debate all at once on one stage
so they're splitting it into debate 1a
which will be next Wednesday the 26 and
then debate 1b which will be Thursday
the 27th ten candidates on each part so
the obvious question who gets to be in
part one who gets to be in part two and
one thing that the DNC and NBC News I
guess together wanted to avoid is the
idea of a sort of top tier debate versus
the kids table so to speak and really
mix up people that are polling well and
people that are polling less well and
the way that NBC News says they did it
is by separating the candidates into two
groups the met the the top polling
people and the lesser well polling
people and including some from both
groups in both debates to make sure that
there is some mix now the requirements
to even qualify for this debate were
either one percent in three qualified
polls or 65 thousand donors with certain
minimums per state and a certain minimum
number of states the particulars don't
so much matter the important thing is
that lots of people who would not have
made it on the basis of polling did
receive the sufficient number of
donations and on that basis are going to
be participating in the debates which i
think is good if you're able to show I
mean I hate that money plays the role
that it plays in our elections but just
because you're not
1% if you otherwise are generating a
significant number of donations I do
think you should be allowed to
participate I think a lot of these
people polling under 1 and under two are
going bye-bye before the next series of
debates but that's the whole point of
doing these things many of these people
will be gone from the next set of
debates unless they really impress the
audience in these first debates and
that's a great thing so let's look at
the list what you will notice is that on
Wednesday June 26th
you have Cory Booker Elizabeth Warren
battle Roarke Amy Klobuchar John Delaney
Tulsi Gabbard who Leon Castro Tim Ryan
Bill DeBlasio and Washington governor
jay Inslee effectively what has happened
is that the first debate is basically
Elizabeth Warren versus a bunch of
people polling almost nothing plus Cory
Booker and beto who are polling a couple
of points but don't seem to have any
reasonable shot in my mind at impressing
people so sincerely and so
overwhelmingly that they are going to be
in this thing we'll talk in a second
whether that would be good for Elizabeth
Warren or not and then in the second
night of these debates you have the
heavier hitter frontrunner you've got
Bernie Sanders and Kamala Harris of
course Vice President Joe Biden and Pete
Budaj edge who are the frontrunners with
the exception of Elizabeth Warren who
will be on the first night and then
joining them michael bennett marianne
williamson who i have a hard time
believing she even really has the the
financial support required but ok I
don't I'm not being conspiratorial I'm
just shocked that she got 65,000
donations Eric's wall well Kirsten
Gillibrand Andrew yang has made the
stage which will be interesting John
Hickenlooper as well so the second night
is every other frontrunner but Elizabeth
Warren meaning Biden Sanders Budaj edge
and Kamala Harris does this help her
hurt Elizabeth Warren there's two ways
to think about it okay one approach is
this is bad for Elizabeth Warren because
the second night will have a bigger
audience because there are more big
players who want to see their favorite
debate rather than people they aren't
supporting the second night has more
polling support in the aggregate in
total
and so Elizabeth Warren just is not
going to get the exposure that some of
these other candidates are going to get
there's another view though which is now
this is good for Elizabeth Warren first
of all this is the first debate of the
season meaning it's going to be very
well viewed it's gonna have a
significant audience and therefore it's
not right to assume that night two will
have more audience night one is going to
have more audience the other argument to
be made in favor of Elizabeth Warren is
she is clearly the top dog on the first
night therefore she's going to do really
well against lesser known less popular
candidates the the sort of wrinkle in
that argument is that although Elizabeth
Warren is clearly the front-runner of
the first night of candidates she's not
necessarily the best debater of that
first night because as I've spoken about
before I love Elizabeth Warren's
policy-based approach it's been helping
her in the polls will talk about those
polling numbers momentarily which
continue to improve for Elizabeth Warren
but in large stage debates I don't
actually think she's that great so it'll
be very interesting to see whether
ultimately this is good or bad for
Elizabeth Warren to be the segregated
frontrunner in night one net net net I
think it probably hurts her a little bit
I think it will give her a great
opportunity to pull some support from
some of the other people she's debating
against but that in the context of
against the bigger frontrunner like
Biden and Sanders it's a missed
opportunity for her by being on a
different night but this is just the
bait one a right there's going to be a
lot of opportunities so this is this is
just the beginning what I also am really
interested in seeing is the Bernie
versus Biden dynamic in night two of the
debate which again this is next week not
this week we've just learned what the
lineups are going to be Bernie during
that Fox News Town Hall said Oh Joe's a
friend of mine but we have policy
differences or whatever however it was
that he worded it that's going to be
very interesting and it's also going to
be interesting to see if any of what I
call the one-percenters explode because
there have been listen Andrew yang who I
like has a following that says as soon
as Andrew yang gets on a debate stage
with these other candidates he is going
to explode
in the polling because people are just
going to absolutely love what he has to
say we'll see if that happens I'm
excited to see if that happens Tulsi has
a similar following that says as soon as
Tulsi Gabbard is given the opportunity
to debate these other candidates she
will come through as the right path
forward for the United States of America
well we're going to see very soon she's
polling I think 0.4% right now or maybe
it's up to like 0.7 we'll see um jay
inslee is a guy who has almost no
support but his supporters believe that
he is really offering the best package
of policies and that as soon as America
is fully introduced to jay Inslee jay
Inslee 'he's polling is going to take
off like a rocket ship or whatever
metaphor you want to use we'll see and
I'm excited to see it and we'll talk
more about the pre-debate stuff that's
going on later in the week but probably
more early early next week